words of Tyga you can make it nasty
before Valentine's Day next Wednesday at
Encore Beach Club David Hayden is here
to give us a taste of the You Don't Own
Me Party you see what I did there all
the Tiger lyrics yeah yeah I hope you
guys got that out there so welcome to
the show let's talk about this You Don't
Own Me Party the name first and foremost
where does it come from the classic song
well a little bit and so you don't know
me it's uh you know our Twist of a
Valentine's Day party so it's an annual
party we do every year it's our fourth
one
um so it's going to be at Encore Beach
Club at night uh Wednesday February 8th
um and you could expect to see some
really cool photo activation there's
going to be a champagne Tower I'm sure
you love champagne I do yes yes um we
have the dude twins performing so the
music
on the show oh yeah I love them they're
so good um so we're really looking
forward to to that event okay and what's
the message behind the You Don't Own Me
Party well this party's really for
everybody it's not like you're typical
romantic Valentine's celebration this is
a little special where everybody can
come celebrate you know it's just a
great time and what and what else is
coming up because when nightlife is busy
you guys just added tiger what else is
coming up on the on the list well we
have a lot of exciting things coming up
so we have Encore Beach Club so opening
up uh March 3rd okay so full season full
season's back pumpkin is here I know
it's crazy oh my gosh and then right
after that March uh 10th through the
12th we have art of the wild which is uh
yes our music festival so it's day and
night you can see artists like black
coffee rules to soul and uh you know
just a stacked lineup of great artists
that's so dope and what does it mean for
you guys over at when nightlife to have
Tyga on the lineup now
we're so excited to have tiger now just
announced it I mean it's incredible
feedback so we're just really happy to
have him favorite Tiger song Go all of
them no I'm just looking at the list in
so long you've got so many features it's
gonna be a party for sure when he's on
the stage
um where can people get tickets for You
Don't Own Me for Valentine's Day or
pre-valentine's day March 8th or
February 18th Wednesday nightlife.com
when nightlife.com okay simple as that
you guys You Don't Own Me at Encore
Beach Club nights of Wednesday February
8th thank you David thank you